- [Voiceover] Okay, this video is about
the long essay section on
the AP U.S. History exam.
Now you might also have heard this called
the free response question or FRQ.
I think it is officially
called the long essay question,
so that's what we're
gonna go with for now.
Now this is the last essay
that you'll be writing
on the AP exam,
and you get 35 minutes to do it,
which is considerably
shorter than the DBQ section,
but the nice part about this is that
you don't have so spend so much time
looking at all of those primary documents.
The more challenging part, however,
is that it's drawing on
your own personal knowledge
of the subject matter.
So unlike the DBQ where
you're analyzing documents
and looking at just
what's in front of you,
here you're really using
your own background
understanding of U.S. history
and also bringing up specific details
to help you make an argument.
So on this section of the exam
you're gonna have the option to choose
between two different essay prompts
and you can choose which of them
you want to write about.
You only have to write about one.
And of course, I recommend
writing about the one
where you feel most confident.
Maybe it's about a
topic that you like more
or maybe it's a topic
about what you feel like
you can give more information,
but in these cases always
play to your strengths.
So out of the two prompts that I was given
there was one about whether
the American Revolution
was actually revolutionary,
and then there was this question about
whether the New Deal was actually new
or whether it was more
conservative in nature.
Now I love the New Deal,
so that is the question
that I want to take on here.
Plus I can remember a
lot about the New Deal
off the top of my head,
so that's gonna give me a lot
of extra information to work with.
So of this 35 minutes that you have on
the long essay question,
I would recommend that you spend maybe
five to 10 minutes of that
and I think 10 minutes would really be max
to plan your essay.
To write a little outline for yourself,
to decide what your thesis is going to be,
and come up with a game
plan that is gonna direct
the rest of your writing time,
which should be the rest
of the time that you spend.
The 25 to 30 minutes in this exam period.
Now again, your mileage may vary on this.
You might be the sort of
person who can plan really fast
and take a lot of time writing,
or you might be the sort of person who
knows that they can write pretty fast
so they can spend some more time planning,
but I think this is just
kind of a good overall
guideline for how you want
to be spending your time.
Okay, so once you've taken a look
at each of the topics
for the essay prompts
and decided which one you want,
the next step is to read the prompt itself
really carefully.
You want to make sure
that there aren't any
sort of hidden strictures
in there that might
direct what you are allowed
to write about in the prompt
and what you aren't allowed
to write about in the prompt.
Okay, so let's take a
look at this question.
"Some historians have
argued that the New Deal
"was ultimately conservative in nature.
"Support, modify, or
refute this interpretation,
"providing specific evidence
to justify your answer."
Okay, so it seems like
the heart of this is about
whether the New Deal
was conservative
or radical.
And I think in this context
the word conservative
doesn't mean politically
conservative or right-leaning,
but rather conservative as in the sense of
keeping something that existed before.
So were the ways of a society conserved
over time or did they change over time?
One thing I notice about this question
is that it really doesn't
give us much in the way
of a specific timeframe to talk about.
So it doesn't say talk
about whether the New Deal
was conservative or radical in the period
between 1920 and 1940,
it just asks us to say in
the grand scheme of things
do you think the New Deal was ultimately
a conservative or radical movement.
So that means if we want
to we could actually
talk about a lot of different things
really up to the present.
And it doesn't even say that we only have
to talk about the United States.
I mean, this is AP U.S. History,
so the bases of everything you're writing
has to be about American society,
but there's nothing
saying you can't compare
American society to other
nations in this time period.
Okay, so our time scope is broad
and even our geography
is relatively broad.
All right, so how do we decide
what we're gonna write about?
Well, I think it's given
us three main options here.
Can support this idea.
So we could argue that yes
the New Deal was conservative.
We can refute and say no
the New Deal was radical.
It's not conservative at all.
Or we can modify,
which might take the form of saying
oh, maybe it was both
conservative and radical
or maybe you even want to say
this is not the right question to ask.
So the modify option is kind of like a
both or neither
kind of way of looking at things.
Now how do we decide which of these three
arguments we want to make?
I think one of the most useful things
you can do at this stage
is just make a list
of things that you
might want to talk about
in this essay.
So if we're thinking
about the conservativeness
or the radicalness of the New Deal,
what sorts of things might we bring up?
So first let's just refresh ourselves
on what the New Deal was about.
And the New Deal was this package
of programs
which were passed during
the Great Depression
by Franklin Delano Roosevelt
as a means to try to restart
the American economy.
And people often talk about the New Deal
kind of taking the three forms of relief,
for people who are suffering,
for people who need immediate aid.
Recovery,
to try to get the economy
back on track.
And reform.
Ways to try to change laws,
change the way the economy worked
so that something like
the Great Depression
didn't happen again.
And with the New Deal we often think about
this kind of alphabet soup of agencies.
There's the CCC, the
Civilian Conservation Corps.
There's the TVA, the
Tennessee Valley Authority.
There's the NRA, the National
Recovery Administration.
And the WPA, the Works
Progress Administration.
And these were all
programs that were intended
to get people back to work,
to try to modernize the country,
and to try to moderate relationships
between workers and corporations.
So what are some of the
other things we know
about the New Deal?
Well, the New Deal was a
reaction to the Great Depression,
which was brought on by some irresponsible
banking in the 1920s,
a time of what was known
as laissez-faire economics,
which kind of said the government
was to keep its hands out of the economy.
Laissez-faire is French for
let them do what they will,
so let the economy do whatever it wants.
Well, this all right came crashing down
somewhat literally in 1929
with the stock market crash.
And then for another three years
the Depression continued
to get worse and worse.
Hoover had a largely hands-off approach
to the Great Depression,
and so he's creamed in
the election of 1932
by Franklin Delano Roosevelt,
who promises that he's gonna
get things back on track.
And so Roosevelt had a really experimental
response to the Great Depression.
It was kind of a try something
and see if it works approach.
So he and his administration just kind of
threw a lot of different
experimental solutions
at the problem to see what they could do
about the Great Depression.
But the other thing we
know about the New Deal
is that in the end it didn't really work.
Now this was partly
because the Supreme Court
rolled back a lot of the New Deal programs
saying that they weren't constitutional,
which led FDR into his
famous court packing scheme
where he tried to add new justices
to the Supreme Court,
basically tilting it in his favor.
And he failed at that.
And the Depression continued to get worse
throughout the end of the 1930s.
It really wasn't until World War II
that the mobilization for war,
the American manufacturing for the war,
got the United States out
of the Great Depression.
So I think it's clear that the New Deal
was this really unique
period in the United States
when the government just tried whatever
they could think of in order to try to
improve the economy.
But I think the question is
if we think about the basic assumptions
of the New Deal itself,
were those radical or
were they conservative?
Okay, let's pause here to think about that
a little bit more and in the next video
we'll decide which way we want to lean
and think about how to write that essay.